she serves as the Honda insider and the
Honda inside a report right now for the
Stanley Cup Linda Cohen how ILC bridge
I'm very thrilled to be on your program
as I always am thank you for having me
no laughs the other that's very uh
that's very formal I'd look I I
appreciate you coming on the show Linda
um what do you what do you have what
what do you have
LC what do you have what's going on in
this couple right now wait wait wait
first of all before we get to the
phenomenon Pittsburgh Penguins can we
talk I overheard you talking and ripping
my mascot mr. Matt no your men and I go
way back okay and we had a Sports Center
commercial together do you remember
those days he brought my suntan oil on
my back I mean that was back in the 90s
we had a very close thing going on now
Matt okay and hazel what's happened to
mr. met Linda what happened let's go out
obviously I exited his life and it was
gone all downhill he's our--our him and
the rest of the franchise yes he's
gotten he's gotten just deeper into his
own depression Linda yes ever since that
SPF moment between you and mr. met but I
mean is it possible that's Matt Harvey
in there is it possible you know what
yes I mean here's the deal
somehow someway Matt Harvey has a
connection to all of us I don't know
what it is yet but it has he had he is
not at fault he's got to be there's got
to be so
what for we get on to this this yes do
you it is this not symbolic of the 2017
Mets season Linda that's a leading
question but what do you think no it
absolutely is I mean what its input it
onto the heading what else could go
wrong I mean what is next
they'll be scandal with mrs. mess that
is what's next
no convinced of it maybe that's where
Matt Harvey is no you're just the
picture is what's going to happen here
what missus met will not show to the
stadium and they'll have to knock on her
door she'll be she'll be in her pajamas
or her necklace
all right yeah then the missus met will
wind up splashed all over the back pages
of the Daily News
because mr. met has now been switched
out from inside okay because it's now
another human being in that big monster
dome of a baseball whatever by the way
whatever happened a bullpen car remember
that the Mets always used to drive in an
open car with mrs. met you know yeah I
don't know it's that's how the franchise
has just taken a turn for the world the
bullpen car mister man showing off a
digit you know it's anyway let's talk
hockey because I know obviously
everybody wants to hear another do about
that no I seriously no here's the thing
it is great principle but you believe
this 25 years at ESPN is the first time
they're sending me on the road really
entire Stanley Cup final and I'm
ecstatic and it's been a awesome and
easiest thing where do I begin I begin
with coming into this series now you
know that you know the whole set up
Nashville exciting country music the
whole deal your series now [ __ ] ships to
Nashville where it's kind of a big deal
there and at the same time the Country
Music Awards are going to be there and
they never saw that coming
those are the two biggest events rich me
in this town you know until the Titans
do something sure um you know again but
but the point it doesn't two big events
and they're coinciding and it's
desperate times on Saturday because
Nashville's down o2 and the Penguins
even though they're the reigning champs
everybody was thinking this could be you
know everything was going right for this
natural predator team in their first Cup
final
they had a goalie named pecker in a
who's been a veteran who's finally got
to a cup final so he gets to the Cup
final and he turns into somebody else
because this is not the same pecker in a
that was the rock of the franchise for
the first three rounds of the postseason
and he's been bad she hasn't made one
quality save and that has a lot to do
with the Penguins having it two games to
none Lee watch was even asking Darius
Rucker play goalie while he's there for
the CMA what do you think I don't I
don't know but if he can't you know I
have a history a cinema you know in all
seriousness no do you think la Violette
makes a change what do you think
use the thing I don't think you can I
think he deserves a shot to start Game
three but my leash is very very short
and I would bring in the rookie backup
you see sorrows who no one ever heard of
this week until last night most people
don't think he peg arena had a backup
but he does exist because he's the thing
I mean it's hard when you're a head
coach you know you know this from any
sport it's hard to let emotions get in
the way I'll tell you back with the
Penguins in the Ottawa the Ottawa series
when you know there was some that
thought you know that went to a game
seven I mean I
I'm frowned upon Mike Sullivan taking
marc-andre flurry out and bringing mad
money and when he was healthy because
you know the emotions got there and you
say well we wouldn't have been here if
it wasn't for Marc Andre flurry but
Mike's old and didn't let emotion get in
the way put Matt Murray back in there
and my goodness he along with Jake
canceled two rookies on this Penguins
team are the big reasons not Malkin and
Crosby but gentle and Mari
sounds like a loss first does gensoul
and Murray are the reasons why the
Penguins have a two games to none lead
yeah just keep dialing those guys up I
mean yeah that's what they've done I
mean it's really been incredible how the
Predators have held the Penguins down
for you know extended minutes if not
periods at a time yes and then Linda
three minutes go by and the whole thing
has gotten out of hand and that has got
to play in their minds and certainly
Renee's Minds if Flavia let keeps them
in the net when they go back to the home
ice in Nashville Linda what do you think
about yeah absolutely we'll see the
thing with the Penguins yeah they've
been it probably you can make a case
they've been outplayed by the Predators
five of the six periods that that's been
played that's really honestly because
but the Penguins are an opportunistic
team I love that word but it's it's so
fitting for penguins because they have
the highly skilled players and when they
have an opportunity they will score and
they went over seven on the power play
yesterday but the problem with the
problem with the Predators is they were
so busy killing off seven penguin power
plays
that drains them and they lose any kind
of momentum to generate offense of their
own
so what Nashville has to do heading into
Game three obviously Peck arena has to
return to being Pekka Rinne a being
within the hometown crowd you know
they've only lost one game all
postseason at Bridgestone Arena it's
very loud there there's seven and one
there but they also have to stay out of
the penalty box it doesn't matter if
they kill off penguin power plays it
keeps them from generating they're all
on offense so that's what Nashville has
to find a way I'm not saying the series
is over but obviously riches you know
Nashville has to win on Saturday then it
will be over we don't we came up with an
idea that if Renee can't perform well
that maybe they just stack how many
would it take Brockman 28 catfish if you
yeah about 29 cat says just stack the
catfish inside the pipes and just even a
bunch of catfish just a big mass of fish
would stop seventy-seven percent of the
shots that the I don't like that not
only that a good point I mean just the
smell alone you wouldn't have any
opposing forward in the air the net and
I just totally heard them all they
wouldn't even get a shuttle now does
does the NHL like this that we're
talking about catfish I mean because or
just they just spell your name right
type stuff Linda in all seriousness
because I mean makeups on the line here
and we're just talking about fish being
throwing on the ice you know I'm we're
so yeah yeah no I hear you listen I
think I think they do like it I think
they love that Nashville's in the final
I think they love all this other side
bar stuff catfish you know catfish Keith
Urban Carrie Underwood you name it they
love it because it gets look at someone
like you rich talking about the Stanley
Cup final now if I have to be talking
about it anyway but not in this not in
this vein so as we know we're not the
best if not work for the catfish I'd be
talking about how Mr met slipped the
middle thing with only three three
actual fingers and the thumb four digits
no we don't want yes that's what makes
mr. vet so special I mean how many
mascots can do that when they don't have
enough digits and I don't even have one
sure half is an illusion that he did
seriously let's see the Philly Phanatic
pulled that one off you know I'm saying
exactly but
oh yeah what can I tell you what so yes
so the Spanish a loves it anytime they
could be talked about in any fashion
that is positive and you know catfishes
uh you know it's okay it's a fun story
so so that's good but we'll see how it
plays out but it's been great I couldn't
really have you know I loved it are you
going to the CMAs are you going to the
Country Music Awards are you going I
don't know can you get me in I need to
meet Keith Urban he's my love of my life
okay he is on my list I know he's a
married man to Nicole Kidman but you
know she's a very busy woman
when you say no what is one of lists are
you referring to what are you referring
to that what kind of list everybody's
got the list okay so on that list Keith
Urban
mr. met well no missing rather you know
need to be on the list because I told
you about our past relationship back
okay you checked our you know on the
list is when you you know you haven't
gone in that direction yes I really
wanted this game with you god you want
to get now that's the insider report
we're looking for what else you go there
it is yeah you know right now Keith
Urban's uh you know he stops at this
moment I live in the moment I live in
the present and I'm heading to Nashville
okay obviously he's number one let us
know me mister meant number one Linda I
love you take care of yourself okay
YouTube that's rich I had figure that so
Linda come the Rich Eisen shown weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches